come in come in welcome how are you
we're live so yeah yeah jump on a mic
Nikki Bella hi how are you do you know
Jim Norton Jim I feel like we've met hey
have you ever been chased down the
street one time I was chased on the
street actually brie and I by Amy
Schumer is that right yeah Nashville
yeah we walked into this bar to hear
guitar playing and we heard it for a bit
had a few beers and we walked out and we
hear someone yelling our name and we
turn to his Amy and she had just got
done filming trainwreck with John so it
was a while ago and she's like I just
want to say I'm he trained at old divas
it was great to work with John blah blah
blah we took a photo so yeah we happened
to know Jim Nicole is dating John Cena
yes IRL in real life and brie is married
to Daniel Bryan oh okay so you're deep
in the wrestling community we are Wow
and and and Nicole is one of the
Smackdown female superstars that's right
and the longest wish I was what you
breathe I feel like you retired and then
the word was you know spend more time
with family and everything and then
immediately your husband's back yeah
your sister's back on the road funny
it's funny because that Smackdown it's
literally my mom's husband is Johnny Ace
who you say is a former wrestler and
people Perry might have known him on WWE
so we literally turned into like
wrestling royalty it's pretty crazy yeah
but so on Tuesdays I get to see my
stepdad Johnny Ace and I have my love
John Cena there and then my
brother-in-law Daniel Bryan and it's
like a big family event set briefs not
there yeah except me and my mom are
doing like sleepovers together see
they're mad I'm scared to stay home but
it's nice because Bryan I do get a lot
more time together and you know we're
trying to start a family so it's a
bigger process than what I realized do
you get mad winning cuz he's like gone
because he Bryan had to retire because
of concussions like he got a lot of
concussion they were saying at one point
they were getting so seriously he was
having seizures like good
WWE was just like you can't be in a ring
anymore we won't allow you to write but
like I feel like every interview that I
read that he does he says no I'm getting
back in a ring I want to get back in a
ring they won't let me but I'm trying to
convince some dude oh it's so
frustrating it's our biggest argument in
our marriage but it's he of course he
would love to you know but we don't get
to choose our health unfortunate how old
is he
um he's 35 okay that's not old to be
retiring so I get why you're 35 you
started doing nowhere for him but um you
know unfortunately it's just that you
don't get to choose your health and what
you know happens to your body but we do
get to choose our next 20 years of life
or next 50 years which we're lucky that
david obie does have good doctors and
that they care yeah and I'm like Brian
the minute that I that we have a baby
and you hold that baby it's all gonna be
over and you know Shawn Michaels told
him that he's like you don't care about
your body and everything that happens to
it and tell you have a child and he's
like wrestling becomes way down here
because that child takes over your whole
life and I think that's what he needs I
need a hurry up so you're just trying to
work for Brian what do you think you
should do if you can't wrestle what
should he do it's just school yeah well
he actually did get accepted to ASU but
then WB called and he got the job as a
GM the GM of SmackDown which he's loving
he's like an on camera with you know
some creative he's the host on talking
smack on the W which work amazing it's
really good yeah and then he was
commentating with Mauro on the
cruiserweight classic on the WB network
which he loved and so I think for him it
was like he was going to school to do
permaculture and then also not all this
came and he gets to still be a part of
wrestling okay
what's permaculture so it's a it's a
style of living where you let your you
put your land together and it's natural
habitat and you can live off your land
so we live in the desert so we have
desert plants and where they're planted
and they can kind of grow on their own
and produce food without using too much
water we use like the natural water that
Arizona gives us I haven't either
Mountain gave me a small cactus I don't
know how much to water it I'm afraid of
drowning it like
yeah that would be I wonder cacti absorb
water though you don't need to water
them that much right I don't know week
maybe yeah I put a giant well I total
Bellas is the show that's coming out
further your sticking out total divas
yes so total Bella's is Wednesday
October 5th 8 p.m. only on E
so you're dragging episodes and you're
dragging John Cena and Daniel Bryan into
becoming full-fledged like reality TV
yeah they actually were excited about
total Bella's because especially Bryan
cuz he's like finally everyone can hear
from me he sits in the interview chair
he gets to tell his perspective about
stuff going on and I think the really
important thing about total Bellas for
Brian is that you see him go through the
process is finding out the bad news of
never being able to wrestle again and he
tried so hard to be strong about it but
he couldn't right and you kind of see
him you know just not take it well and I
think people will relate with that you
know when your dreams get taken from you
but you know as we see now he's the GM
Smackdown and he's loving it so there's
a positive ending to it absolutely Jim
performs stand up for a long time but
then realize he was not funny
I give dramatic talks now I just do my
acting all kidding aside folks and it
works out really well they know it's
great that's I think you would be great
at stand-up I don't know I done it and
it was just hard and it was scary well
there's a comedy I think a comedy store
something in Phoenix Arizona I'm sure
they need talent there so you can come
aside that wouldn't be me whatever you
watch the show thank you for stopping by
real quickly story from one of your
interviews and by the way to John Cena
did this promo as it's called in
wrestling on talking smack where I felt
like he was just being himself yeah he
was amazing amazing amazing I was
actually well it's cute cuz he called me
out because I have literally was just
sitting there like staring out and
watching cuz I just loved everything he
knows me and I was like oh wow and like
I loved it because if you go back and
look at Renee
like you even see her arms start getting
super red and I was like thinking like
Oh Superman [ __ ] smack is great it
gets very yes I love it but John he's
just man he's amazing Sam I will say I
was a little sad at WrestleMania ever
known it was SummerSlam I saw you
retired the brie mode sure there was no
Brie
that's okay I get it you want me to keep
wearing it no I just was a little hurt
Bree no no you want to be a mom so he
can retire the shirt I am gonna make a
comeback after I have my first child are
you sure better go back on yeah hell
yeah I am
what now I've been intimidating brie
mode and then you can make it
we're headed to Napa Valley next week
and it's like no brie motive you guys
pick a nap when you're there see it
doesn't work where you take a quick
break
quick single break thank you very much
ladies and we'll be back right after
this